miles de extranjeros repatriados de
Sudán y decenas de miles de ciudades
obligados a exiliarse esta es una de las
consecuencias de la guerra por el poder
entre el jefe del ejército sudanés el
general App del y el líder de los
paramilitares fuerzas de apoyo rápido
Mohamed
muchos países evacuaron a su personal
diplomático y a sus ciudadanos pero los
sudaneses se enfrentan a un dilema
arriesgar sus vidas en las carreteras o
quedarse en sus casas en una situación
inviable a menudo sin agua ni
electricidad los que deciden irse
intentan llegar a Sudán del sur centro
África Egipto o Etiopía desde que
comenzaron los combates más de 14.000
ciudades llegaron a Egipto mientras que
más de 3.500 personas huyeron a través
de la frontera etíope la región de
darfur es otro punto caliente del
conflicto en los últimos días los
ataques contra la población civil
recrudecieron lo que ha obligado a
decenas miles de personas a cruzar la
frontera con Chad nosotros y nuestros
hijos somos Víctimas de los
enfrentamientos vinieron hombres armados
a pedirnos que nos fuéramos y nos
encontramos aquí en la naturaleza Esto
no es justo la frontera con Sudán del
sur también está experimentando una
afluencia de refugiados según acnur se
espera que lleguen hasta 180,000
sudaneses a este país que se está apenas
recuperando de un amortífera Guerra
Civil
lo que me preocupa es que hoy estamos
hablando de miles de personas que se
trasladan a Chad o a Sudán del sur o
hacia Egipto y Etiopía o que se
desplazan internamente
prolonga no estaremos hablando de miles
sino de cientos de miles de personas
dos semanas después del inicio de la
guerra los enfrentamientos continúan
mientras el equilibrio de poder entre
los dos bandos sigue siendo incierto